Ich würde Ihnen das SQC-Präsident führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Andreas Hoffmann.
Herr Hoffmann, könntest du Ihre Nachname und Vorname nach Sambush tabieren?
Mein Vorname ist Avi Anton, NW Nordpol, DVDora, RRW Richard,
EWE-Mail, Avi Andreas, SV Siegfried und mein Nachname
Hoffmann, Avi Heinrich, Ovi Otto, FV Fritz, nochmal FV Fritz,
NW Martha, Avi Anton, NW Nordpol und nochmal NW Nordpol.
WN, danke schön, Herr Hoffmann.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genergebaut?
20 Jahre alt.
Ich verstehe nicht.
Wir bohren am 22. September 1975.
Okay, danke schön.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1 Meter 80 groß und wiege aktuell ca. 80 Kilogramm.
80 Kilogramm, richtig?
Richtig.
Ja, gut.
Danke schön für die Information.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, was wir beschwerden haben Sie?
Also ich komme heute zu Ihnen.
Ich habe seit ungefähr einer Woche, habe ich leichte, dumpfe Oberbauchschmerzen
und habe gemerkt, dass ich auch etwas gelb geworden bin.
Ich bin gelb geworden.
Ich habe ungefähr eine Woche kaum Appetit.
Okay, kaum Appetit.
Sie haben Oberbauchschmerzen, wo genau tut es?
Im Oberbauch.
Ganz Oberbauch.
Ja, Oberbauch, genau, rechte Seite, vielleicht mehr, als Sie Ihnen gesagt haben.
Richtig, rechte Seite.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
vorbei 1 ist leichter, um 10 unerträglich.
Also 4 bis 5.
4 bis 5, ja.
Okay, wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Dumpfartig, bohren.
Dumpfartig, ja.
Dumpfartig.
Und haben Sie Überkeit oder Erbrochen?
Ich habe einmal erbrochen.
Einmal erbrochen.
Ich habe auch ein wenig.
Ja.
Und wie konsistent ist erbrochen?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Welche Konsistenz hat erbrochen?
Nahrungsreste oder gelbig?
Nahrungsreste und gar nicht, beides.
Okay.
Und Sie haben aus den Schmerzen,
irgendwelche Wartenkörperteile aus?
Ja, so bisschen in den Rücken wenig.
Rücken.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser?
Nach dem Essen oder beim Bewegung?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich habe einfach Fragen,
Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Ich habe kein Fieber, ich habe auch.
Kein Fieber, ich habe auch.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schütterprost oder Schweiß?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Schüttergang oder beim Wasserlass?
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Keine Probleme.
Und wie ist der Appatit?
Weg, ganz weg.
Seit wann haben Sie...
Sehr wenig.
Seit wann haben Sie wenig Appatit?
5 bis 6 Tagen.
5 bis 6 Tage.
Haben Sie schon in letzter Zeit Angewicht verloren?
Ich habe jetzt ungefähr 3 kg gehabt.
Ungewollt?
Ja, ungewollt.
3 kg.
Und wie ist der Schlag?
Normalerweise gut.
Okay.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen für Ihre Vorgeschichte.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Mir wurden die Mandeln nachaus genommen.
Mandeln?
Das war, als ich 20 Jahre alt war, also vor 30 Jahren.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig, oder?
Selten.
Welche Medikamente?
Parastomol meistens.
In welche Dosehen nehmen Sie Parastomol ein?
Weiß ich nicht.
Und ich habe eine Frage,
die Ihren Lebensgewandheiten...
Rauchen Sie Zigarette?
Ich rauch nicht.
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Wie viele Menge Urtauber trinken Sie?
Ich trinke so 1-3 Flaschen am Tag Bier.
1 bis 3 Flasche Bier.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Seit so 2 Jahren ungefähr.
Ich verstehe nicht.
Ich bin ein
2 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Träumen?
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Träumen.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Ihre Familien,
Anamnese, gibt Ihre Familie
chronische Erkrankungen,
leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch.
Mein Vater ist einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Schlaganfall verstorben?
Meine Mutter lebt noch.
Darf ich fragen,
ob Sie sich verstanden haben?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Sie ist gesund?
Sie ist junger und gesund.
Sie ist voll.
Was habe ich?
Ja, voll.
Ja, sehr.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Ihr dich geworden ist?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie aufgestoßen?
Ein bisschen aufgestoßen.
Ja.
Haben Sie Ihre Körperteile
Hautveränderungen bemerkt?
Aus gelblicher Farbeveränderungen?
Nein.
Sie sind schon gebliefert geworden.
Wo sind die gebliefert veränderungen?
Ja, in den Augen und am Körper.
Augen.
Und Körper.
Herr Hofmann, sind Sie bereit?
Ich bin geschieden seit zwei Jahren.
Ich habe mich gebliefert.
Ich habe einen Sohn.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, der liebt bei seiner Mama.
Okay.
Leben Sie allein?
Allein.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Bauimgst.
Sind Sie bei der Arbeit ausgesetzt?
Ja.
Ja, natürlich.
Bauimgst.
Ich habe meine Noten jetzt schnell möglich an.
Sie haben Dunfe, Pauschmerzen,
besonders Reserven,
und auch die Verkaufung.
Sie haben keine Volllegerfüll.
Und haben Sie Allergie?
Ich habe keine Allergie.
Keine Allergie.
Ist Ihnen Unvertehlichkeit begonnen?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Allergie.
Ist Ihnen Unvertehlichkeit bekannt?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Allergie.
Haben Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich mache mir Sorgen.
Kann das Krebs sein, was ich habe?
Um etwas zu sagen,
ist es sehr für Sie.
Mein Nachbar, der war auch Geld geworden.
Nach 3-4 Monaten gestorben.
Ich verstehe sehr gut.
Viele Krankheiten haben ein Lied beschwerten.
Sobald ich etwas zu sagen,
werde ich einfach untersuchen dürfen.
Dazu gehören Labantersuchung,
Körpelier-Untersuchung und Pilgemenze-Untersuchung.
Ich habe eine andere Erfolge.
Aus Panama.
Ich werde eine andere Erfolge.
Ich weiß, dass ich dafür femme.
Da muss ich etwas paar업 machen.
Was yardım punished.
Ich werde ein anderes Putin.
Ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen und dann erst die Körperlihe unterzuholen.
Und Blutabnehmen wahrscheinlich Bauch und Ultraschall durchführen oder fernlassen.
Und danach, wir könnten darüber sprechen.
Aber Sie nehmen bitte etwas und legen Sie auf die Liege und ich komme gleich.
Danke schön.
Sie haben keine volle Gefühle und haben nicht bemerkt, dass Ihr Bauch dick geworden ist.
Richtig.
Sie haben Sie Artennot oder Blutdruck?
Gibt es Ihnen in Ihrer Familie Krebserkrankungen zum Beispiel Onkel, Kante?
Nicht bekamst.
Einmal die Kerbe aufzunehmen.
Hatten Sie gefragt wegen den Stuhlveränderungen oder?
Ich habe schon gesagt, Sie haben keine Probleme mit Stuhlgang.
Ich habe keine Probleme, aber mir ist ein heller Stuhl aufgefallen.
Ah, okay.
Ich glaube, das haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Ich habe schon gefragt, Sie haben Probleme mit Stuhlgang.
Ich habe keine Probleme, ich kann normal auf Toilette gehen.
Aber ich habe einen hellen Stuhl.
Danke schön für diese Informationen.
Es ist sehr wichtig für mich und für Ihre Diagnose.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlverhalten, zum Beispiel Alexander, Verstuttuk und manchmal die Jahre?
Ich habe keine Stuhlprobleme, mir ist nur ein heller Stuhl aufgefallen.
Und jetzt möchte ich noch etwas fragen.
Sie ist Ihnen heller Urin oder Urinbemel?
Er ist dunkel geworden.
Es ist ein bisschen dunkel geworden.
Sie haben schon wegen dieser Beschwerden einen Hausarzt besucht?
Nein, noch nicht.
Oder eine Medikamente?
Nein, auch nicht.
Leiden Sie an Gallenstein?
Nicht bekannt.
Oder ähnliche Probleme?
Ähnliche Probleme?
Gallenbeläsenentschuldung?
Nicht bekannt.
Und auch Alkoholdrogen?
Alle, die vorherkrankt sind.
Okay, ich bin fertig.
Mit Anämenesik ist gut.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Darf ich?
Bitte.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder treten Sie hin und wieder auf?
Immer wieder, immer wieder.
Im Intervall.
Intervall oder?
Ja, immer wieder.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ein bisschen, ich habe auch einmal übergebrochen, habe ich gesagt.
Danke.
Ich verstehe, diese Beschwerden treten.
Nein, Mutter.
Noch andere Kollegen.
Darf ich fragen?
Bitte.
Sind diese Beschwerden nach dem Essen schlimmer geworden?
Ein bisschen, ja.
Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Bitte schön.
Was ist das für ein Schmerzen, die sich in der rechten Schulter ausheben?
Nein.
Okay, ich bin fertig.
Ich habe nur eine Frage.
Diese Patiente, für diese Patiente,
für diese Patiente, für diese Patiente.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ich verstehe.
Das ist eine Frage.
Er hat seit zwei Jahren geschieden.
Ja, er ist geschieden, jetzt genau.
Auf der neuen Part.
Ja, der Ex-Sender-Partner.
Ja, genau, sehr gut.
Ja, das müssen wir erstellen.
Ja, das ist eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Diese Beschwerden treten langsam.
Ja, langsam dumpf.
Ja, das ist eine Frage.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ja, langsam dumpf.
Langsam.
Ich möchte hier so.
Hallo, Herr Oberast.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit?
Ja, bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um
ein 30-jähriger
Herr Anders-Hoffmann.
Er ist 1,80 m
groß und 80 cm schwer.
Er schädelt sich heute bei uns
wegen
seit ungefähr
eine Woche
langsamer
und umdreht.
Er hat eine dumpfartige
epigastische Schmerzen
ohne besondere Ausstrahlung.
Er berichtete
der Patientin,
dass er gelbliche
Veränderungen
von Augen und Schmerzen
bemerkt hat.
Der Schmerz-Charakter
ist dumpfartig
und Schmerzintensität
wurde 5 von 10 bewertet.
Er hat
erwendet,
dass er
eine sparsale
Epigasie hat.
Er hat
eine sparsale Epigasie
und ist ein bisschen über.
Er hat
Fragen nach voller Gefühle
oder
nicht.
Er hat
eine sparsale Epigasie
und
eine sparsale Epigasie.
Er hat
eine sparsale Epigasie
und er hat
eine sparsale Epigasie.
Er ist
Anverordnungen ist nicht bekannt und Anvoroperationen wurden bei den Patienten von 20 Jahren durchgeführt.
Die Patient nimmt sehr seltene Paracetamol ein und in der Familienanamnese Vater ist an Apopilex verstorben und Mutter ist gesund.
Mit welchem Jahre ich verstehe, sage ich nicht.
In Lebensgewohnheiten berichtete der Patient, dass er nicht raucht und Alkohol 1-3 Flasche Bier seit 2 Jahren klingt.
Er ist geschieden, seit 2 Jahren hat einen Sonn, lebt allein, er ist Bauingenieurin.
Bei den Patienten beschütterten keine Allergie und Unverträglichkeiten.
Das war alles.
Was haben Sie für eine Arbeitsdiagnose?
Die Anamnestischenangaben deuten am Ähisten auf eine Hepatocerelar-Carsinone in differential diagnostisch
Die Anamnestischenangaben deuten am Ähisten auf eine Hepatocerelar-Carsinone in differential diagnostisch.
Was spricht gegen einen Gallenblasenstein?
Gallenblasenstein hat zupfertige Schmerzen und Schmerzen.
Im Intervall?
Im Intervall.
Hatte der Kollege gefragt, ja.
Die Patient hat eine Bäsentomatik in Appetence und Gewichtverlust.
Hatte der wirklich Bäsentomatik? Was ist Bäsentomatik?
Eine Bäsentomatik.
Das ist keine Bäsentomatik.
Bäsentomatik, wenn Sie alle drei zusammen haben.
Ja, zusammen haben.
Das ist keine Bäsentomatik.
Danke schön, diese Informationen.
Ja, da hat er nachschweißt.
Er hat keine Febrile Temperatur, keine Nachschweiß, aber er hat in Appetence und in Letzte sei drei Kilogramm umgewohnt.
Ich meine, Sie haben gesagt, die Hepatocerelar-Carsinone.
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, es ist eine gute Differenzialdiagnose, aber es ist nicht die Diagnose, die man sofort stellt.
Richtig?
Weil ich malerweise machen auch Hepatocerelar-Carsinone oder Pankreas-Kopf-Carsinone, normalerweise keine richtigen Schmerzen.
Die machen er zum Beispiel ein dickgeruss ohne Schmerz.
Richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Gut, aber die Patient hat weniger Schmerzen.
Ja, eine sein, aber hat Schmerzen.
Und ungefähr eine Woche.
Aber hat Schmerzen?
Es gibt keine totalen Verschuldung.
Doch, hat er.
Er hat hellen Stuhl, dunkle Ring, richtig?
Ja.
Und ein mechanischem Verschluss.
Oder?
Ja.
Ja oder nein?
Sie haben, danke schön, diese Information.
Aber Gewichtverlust, ich konzentriere auch Gewichtverlust.
Er hat aber gesagt, Inappetenz.
Er hat vielleicht weniger Appetit.
Ah, okay.
Ich möchte jetzt Danke schön für die Informationen.
Also das ist eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Er kann aber trotzdem differenzial diagnostisch,
natürlich auch Pankreas-Kopf-Carsinone, Hepatocerelaris-Carsinone,
Gallen-Wieck-Carsinone.
Also meine Verdachtdiagnose sollte Kolelithiasis sein.
Ja.
Okay.
Und die Franzi-diagnostisch sollte man Hepatocerelar-Carsinone,
Pankreas-Kopf-Carsinone oder Gallen-Wieck-Carsinone in Betracht kommen.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, danke schön.
Wahrscheinlich ein Schulle Züste oder Schulle doch alle Tieresis
mit mechanischem Iktairos.
Okay.
Ja, wissen Sie, was mechanischer Iktairos bedeutet?
Ja.
Was ist ein mechanischer Iktairos?
Wenn Koleg-Dog, Kolegallem weg,
irgendwie verschuldet wird, das bedeutet mechanische Iktairos.
Ganz genau.
Ja, das ist ein ganz genauer Mechanischer Iktairos.
Und auch ein mechanischer Iktairos,
ein paar mechanischer Iktairos,
durch ein Carsinon entstehen?
Ja, natürlich.
Genau.
Ja, Koleg-Dog-Carsinone zum Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel Pankreas-Kopf-Carsinone auch, oder?
Ja.
Oh.
Danke schön.
Und um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich so erst körperliche Untersuchungen durch
führen und Blut abnehmen, um Entzündungparameter,
Leberwerte, die Nierenwerte und Bilirubinwerte umbewerten.
Und ich werde Abdominalsonographie durchführen
und ich Urinstatus kontrollieren.
Ich kontrolliere Urinstatus und Bilirubin im Urin zu festzustellen.
Ja, das müssten Sie nicht machen unbedingt.
Sie können auch einfach ein Laborkontrolle machen,
eine Blutabnahme, da können Sie auch sehen, ob eine Scholestase besteht.
Ja.
Welche Werte sind wichtig für eine Scholestase?
Welche Parameter?
Zuerst Dreck- und Indreckkohlurbine und Alkfellanphosphotas
und Leberwerte, ACT, Alethegeote oder Gehpete.
Ja, klar.
Kann man den hier nicht vergessen, oder?
Ja.
Ich würde auch Lipase mit abnehmen.
Ja, meine Differenzierdiagnose ist Pancreas Kopfkarzenum
und um diese Situation auszuschließen,
würde ich Lipas Werte kontrollieren.
Ja, Amilase brauchen Sie nicht.
Amilase ist eher so ein Mundbereich, nicht im Gangwuchsbereich,
besonders ausgeprägt.
Ja.
Macht meine Deutschland nicht so sehr oft.
Amilas.
Macht man kaum.
Okay, ich bin ein bisschen...
Die Brase ist wichtig.
Ich bin Kinder-Bewürpskerter, ich bin ein bisschen Angst.
Danke.
Und Gottstandard,
Gottstandard Verfahren ist RSP,
kann man durchführen.
Richtig, sehr gut, ja, ganz genau.
Aber vorher müssten Sie natürlich, wie Sie gesagt haben,
ein Abtolensodografie machen.
Ja.
Und wenn Sie keine intrahypatische, extrahypatische Scholastase sehen
oder sehen aber kein Kongrements, ein Stein sehen,
dann muss man natürlich auch an Karzinome denken,
ganz wichtig.
Wir hatten noch nicht, ist natürlich auch,
wenn Sie den Stein nicht gut sehen können,
also den Kongrements,
eine MRCP, ganz gut,
vor einer ERCP.
Ja, das ist radiologisch,
um den Stein zu sehen,
um eine Abflussbehinderung zu sehen.
Ja, haben Sie das verstanden?
Ja, ja, ich sehe das.
Okay, sehr gut, ja.
Und ich empfehle den Patienten,
die stationäre Behandelte,
stationäre Behandelte.
Ja, die müssen sich aufnehmen.
Die müssen sich stationär aufnehmen, ja.
Und Alkohol, Karin,
ich hab die Müllkottin, Raucher,
und Lemes, Zitil, Änderungen
und ja, und Loparoscopie
oder offene Surgery am Ende.
Ja, müssen Sie nicht unbedingt machen.
Ja.
Sie müssen keine Operation unbedingt machen,
wenn Sie den Stein mit ERCP rausbekommen,
dann müssen Sie den nicht operieren.
Ah.
Der kann seine geilen Blase behalten.
Hm.
Müssen Sie nicht rausnehmen,
müssen Sie nicht unbedingt operieren, ne?
Ja.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Ich habe extra Frage, Herr Oberarzt,
extra korporal,
ich tu, wenn ich hier triff, sie kann man...
Nicht bei Geilenstein.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Bei Nierenstein, bei Nierenstein,
aber bei Geilenstein ist mir das nicht bekannt.
Macht man nicht, soweit ich weiß.
Nur bei Neapolitisis.
Danke.
Beide Prüfungen,
sollte man einfacher Krankheit
in Betracht kommen,
ist besser?
Es kommt darauf an,
wenn der Patient gesagt hätte,
ich habe da keine Schmerzen,
ich habe keine Schmerzen,
dann wäre die Diagnose,
Schmer, oder Symptom,
schmerzloser Echerus
ist meistens ein CA.
Aber der Patient hat Schmerzen.
Er hat nicht explizit gesagt,
dass er kollegartige Schmerzen hat,
er hat dumpfe Schmerzen,
die im Intervall auftreten.
Jeder hat andere Schmerzen,
deswegen müssen Sie auch immer an solche Sachen denken.
Okay.
Wenn Patient Inappetenz hat
und gleichzeitig Gewicht verlust,
auch unsere Verdacht,
Diagnose ist Kolelitisis.
Gucken Sie mal, Herr Karakush,
wenn Sie eine Influencer haben,
ist sie bekannt,
dann haben Sie auch keinen Appetit.
Dann nehmen Sie auch Gewicht ab.
Möchtest du?
Ja, okay.
Wenn Patient hat keine Appetenz,
dann kann er nicht.
Das ist ja seit 10 Tagen,
eine Woche hat er erst nur.
Nicht seit 3 Monaten,
nicht seit 6 Monaten.
Und er hat nur 3 kg genommen
im Rahmen dieser akuten Situation.
Okay, danke schön.